سوف اقوم بقراءه
الجزء النصي من الامر لهذه الاسباب فرضت
المحكمه التدبير المؤقته التاليه واحد
بتصويت من قبل 50 مقابل اثنين حكومه
اسرائيل عليها ووفقا لالتزاماتها بموجب
اتفاقيه الاباده الاباده الجماعيه وفيما
يتعلق بالفلسطينيه في غزه ان تقوم باتخاذ
جميع الاجراءات في صلاحياتها من اجل منع
جميع عالي المنصوص عليها وفق الماده
الثالثه ب ذلك قطل اعضاء المجموعه ب
التسبب بضرر بدني او نفسي على اعضاء
المجموعه ثالثا بشكل متعمد التسبب بظروف
تؤثر على الحياه والدمار المادي بشكل كامل
او جزئي وثالثا فرق تدابير مقصود منها منع
الولادات ضمن المجموعه
ولصالحه الرئيس دنه والسيد دونجون
وابراهام وبنوه ويوسف وشوي وبنداري
وروبنسون
وسلام ويوس اور وملت وتشار وبرانش وجاج
ادهك والسيد سبنت وسيد
براك من 15 صوتا مقابل اثنين دوله اسرائيل
عليها ان تتاكد وعلى الفور من ان جيشها لا
يرتكب ايه
اجراءات موصوفه اعلاه وصوت لصالحه دوناهو
بوركن دوبك ابراهام بنوه يوسف شوي وبنداري
وروبنسون
وسلام ويساور ونوتي وتشارلز وور وبراند
وجيد ادهك
وسناك وضده كان سباتن وادك براك ومن في 16
صوتا مقابل صوت واحد على دوله اسرائيل ان
تتخذ جميع الاجراءات
من اجل معاقبه
التاجج ضد ارتكاب الاعباد الجماعيه ضد
المجموعه الفلسطينيه في قطاع غزه من صوت
لصالحه دوناهو
تومكا ابراهام بنونا يوسف شوي بنداري
روبنسن وسلام وسور ونوت وتشارلز
وبران والقاضي جد براك واسكي ضد القرار
و 16 صوتا مقابل واحد على دوله اسرائيل ان
تقوم فورا باتخاذ اجراءات من اجل ضمان
توفير الاحتياجات الانسانيه والمساعدات
الملحه للتعامل مع الوضع الانساني الملح
الذي يواجهه الفلسطيني في قطاع غزه
ولصالحه الرئيس دوناهو ونائب الرئيس تومكا
وابراهام وبنوه ويوسف وشوي وبنداري و و
وسلام ويوا ونتا وتشارلز وث وبران والقاضي
ادك
براكس
اعترض وضده كان القاضي سبتنك وب 15 صوتا
مقابل اثنين على دوله اسرائيل ان تقوم
باتخاذ اجراءات فوريه لمنع تدمير والتاكد
من حفاظ على الاديه المتعلقه بمزاعم
ارتكاب جرائم مباد
جماعيه بموجب البندين الثاني الثالث من
الاتفاقيه و وارتكب الجمعيه ضد اعضاء
المجموعه لصالح القرار الرئيسه دونا
هيو بوكار دوبك ابراهام بنونا يوسف شوي
بنداري وروبنسون وسلام ويوس اوا ونولت
وتشارلز وورث
وبراند ودهوك وكان ضده القاضي سبنت وا
ادهك براك وب 15 صوتا مقابل على دوله
اسرائيل ان تقدم تقريرا الى المحكمه حول
كل
التدابير التي فرضتها المحكمه وخلال شهر
واحد من تاريخ اصدار الامر وصوت لصالحه
الرئيس دوناهو ونائب الرئيس كوبكي والقاضي
تومكا ابراهام بنونا يوسف شوي بنداري
روبنسن سلام
يوسا وشور
وبراند